Turkey's Deputy Prime Minister recently
had some interesting things to say about
the Turks saying that they had quote
abandoned their values and is pleading
with people to rediscover the Koran but
then he made some interesting comments
about women chastity is so important it
is not only a name it is an ornament for
both women and men she will have justice
man will have it too he will not be a
womanizer he will be bound to his wife
he will love his children the woman will
know what is Haram and what is not Haram
she will not laugh in public she will
not be inviting in her attitudes and
will protect her chaste miss now the
reason I thought this was kind of
interesting is because Turkey sorted in
between worlds right now where they are
very secular and that seems to be where
most Turks want to go and they have a
prime minister who is going more in the
other direction but I thought that quote
was really interesting too because he's
sort of saying you know a man has to
kind of step up and do the right thing
but then it veers into women shouldn't
laugh women are allowed to laugh are
they not mouthing I don't know this guy
doesn't seem like a barrel of laughs
that's that reads like the worst
match.com profile like what he's looking
for no no but you know our dads chastity
oh yeah if we need to keep the the women
of Turkey not laughing in public
Jay Leno is available that's true no no
no no yeah this guy sounds like a lot of
fun and it it sounds like um we need to
send jancuga over there to instill a
little low more a little more
agnosticism and and fun in the Turkish
state he left and everything goes to pot
you know what speaking of the power of
jankier he went to Turkey a couple weeks
ago while Turkey had YouTube shut down
by their prime minister by the time Jenk
left turk youtube was back up so i'm
just saying that he can do something
also huge jenna Marbles fans you know
just one correction in the quote when he
said chastity is is important what he
means is suppressing half of the
population is important yeah I mean what
does this have anything else to do with
you know you
you can only hide behind religion so
much until it gets so ridiculous that
people are gonna go it shut up
you don't even nothing you say makes any
sense yeah I laugh like Ethel Merman I
would they block anyway and throw away
the key
I wouldn't you have a great laugh yeah
you would be in a lot of trouble as soon
as one of you says something funny
you're gonna hear it yeah well when does
this when when do we stop taking these
things seriously yes so that's partly so
I almost didn't do this story because we
hear about these things all the time and
look we talk about Saudi Arabia all the
time which is our great ally in the Gulf
where women can't drive nor vote they
are outright they are actually allowed
to be going to be allowed to vote sooner
than they can drive so they just won't
be able to drive to the polling stations
but do we have any right to tell any
country what to do when it comes to any
of this in his defense the women drivers
think I'm kind of on board with I gotta
know I'm kidding I'm kidding
yeah it's interesting because you know
when you talk about morality and like
this is I assume it's just a distraction
this guy is trying to distract from the
other problems of corruption and that is
that their government is accused of and
it seems like it's the it's a fallback
position it's something that they can go
to quickly and distract much like if
you're Saudi Arabia and you want to talk
you want to distract people from your
own problems and we don't want to get
people talking about how women can't
drive you're like those Israelis those
sons of [ __ ]
those Jews how they treat the
Palestinians why we know don't but
ignore the way we treat the Filipinos
who come here to build our stadium so on
and so forth but so what was your
question I think you whatever my
question was I think you do yes we have
a right because you know we do all these
things with these countries Turkey
obviously is an ally of our Saudi Arabia
is an ally of ours for better or worse
so do we have what maybe do we need
tiered allies like you're in the a group
you know eight I mean Canada well we do
but maybe we need to say it more should
we be say because the women thing like
this is half the world isn't it more
than half the world there are more women
than messages when we criticize a
country like Turkey yeah and we make fun
we ridicule this guy which we he
rightfully deserves
but doesn't that empower him to say you
know those the us the you know the evil
Americans are criticizing our culture
and it feeds into what he's trying to
accomplish and actually does him a favor
yeah I don't know it's a tough call
because it's how are you not going to
ridicule this guy yeah I just you get on
board with that I mean and that's the
thing it's like should we go and invade
them over this no we can't and we
shouldn't but when it comes to terms of
you know like you said being an ally
doing business how do you how do you do
this and feel good about yourself as a
government when these other governments
are so oppressive you know it's like
well it's not my mom it's not my sister
it's not my wife well it's somebody
else's and if she's into it she's been
brainwashed I mean that's all there is
to it